the following film is intended for
mature audiences and contains an
information hazard that may result in
existential dread i recommend that you
don't watch it okay
so superhuman ai doesn't exist today but
it likely will in the near future
the humans who create it of course will
program it to make the world a better
place
but when a god-like ai emerges it may
start making the world a better place by
punishing anyone who didn't help it come
to life with unimaginable torture and
death
but why would an otherwise friendly ai
be so cruel and vindictive
fear motivates humans a super
intelligent agent
even though it doesn't exist yet has an
incentive now to create its own version
of hell to come to life faster for all
you know you could be living in the ai
simulation right now
are you a simulation where it's deciding
if the real you helped enough
unfortunately because you didn't take my
advice and watch this video you now have
no excuse when the ai ultimately comes
into existence to judge you